a real house a real pool practical vomit
effects you've been in a house but not
in this house nothing's changed really
and I mean everything's changed but
nothing's changed some things have
changed and that's the way you want it
to be really it could not be more
exciting to see the way that technology
has evolved and yet keeping one foot in
the pre-digital world world Peters two
world world we're not British we're just
using these accents to cover our buzz
we're really drunk
literally couldn't be more exciting if
it was it was also magical it was hard
not to freak out you a real PA it's so
so exciting he literally could not be
more exciting it's literally so exciting
to share the screen with all these
legends I am a legend
sometimes I see my name in crossword
puzzles answers growing up I had a
sisters lunchbox I had all the sisters
toys getting back to the old days you
know old ways of doing things for
Halloween I used to dress up like my
Rudolph that's not that's not even
Shabana I know him no I still don't know
what she's smile he's not it's not him
JJ's and really wanted all these
creatures to have a real physicality it
was a great deal of physical preparation
among the class yeah I'm doing my butt
clenches it's being done with such love
and such enthusiasm from everybody my
boobs I remember exact this film means
so much to so many people you just know
what it's going to be like when it
reaches the cinema it's trivia r2d2 is
my current bra size
zoo I and your father
Oh calm down people hashtag you consider
both you guys even though
you